prête à évacuer eléonore 82 cents à tout
préparer son sac renferme ce qu'il faut
pour 6 khoury fini car depuis plusieurs
mois comme tous les habitants du
quartier eléonore view au rythme des
alertes
une situation difficile pour elle la
peur est omniprésent au verso patronat
cérémonie toiser du matin qu'alimenter
quelles que soient les orcs et en cadeau
dans le cra soca a connu onze est
dissous et moi doit faire opérer et là
concerts off on doit faire une peur qui
s'est manifestée chez elle par
différents symptômes
magali tremblay n'a pas tremblé pour moi
mais ma terrasse centimes atteignant
tremblant danube en moins puisque tâter
la fouillaient popb son meilleur soutien
si sa voisine elles ont vécu ensemble
débordement de la rivière et les images
de la crue reviennent sans cesse elle
est hantée dans le quartier certains
plus jeunes on peut mieux gérer cette
situation de stress permanent
ça me fait pas si pire que ça
personnellement parce que moi je suis
déjà habitué après bois la sirène c'est
un peu gênant ça nous empêche de dormir
pourquoi parce que si tous les cinq
minutes les 15 minutes dont te voilà
quoi par contre difficile pour les
enseignants et les élèves de l'école
située à côté de la rivière de garder
calme et sérénité
celle angoisse même s'ils ne l'expriment
pas par rapport à leur attitude
on sentait l'emploi et pour nous aussi
professionnel on se sent un peu en
danger
on a peur on entend les sirènes on sait
pas si c'est un exercice c'est une vraie
alerte et à le fait aussi que
l'hélicoptère qui
qui démarre et du coup les enfants
regardent l'extérieur et se pose des
questions
voilà on est humain aussi donc du coup
on a un peu peur aussi et même si le
quartier tranquille ces temps derniers
tous ont en tête la saison des pluies
qui arrivent et prie pour que la rivière
ne déborde pas